[Music]
well hello there you're watching the
press preview a first look at what is on
the front pages
as they come in it's time to see what's
making the headlines then with the daily
mirrors associate editor kevin mcguire
and the columnist for the article ali
mirage they will be with us right
through
until midnight so front pages then let's
kick off with the metro
according to the paper some public
transport staff
are concerned that they will fall victim
to aggression
and violence when they try to enforce
rules on mosques in places like london
and scotland
where travellers will still need to wear
them from monday
the financial times again hears from
bosses who are concerned
that too many of their staff are being
pinged by the nhs covert app and forced
into
self-isolation the telegraph reports
that the government
intends to introduce new taxes on cars
and motorcycles to encourage
road users to go carbon neutral
and speaking of taxes a report submitted
to the government has recommended
imposing
a levy on junk food that is according to
the front page of the daily mail
but if you believe the research carried
in the star a can of beer
or two glasses of wine a day could be
good for you
according to the sun a man passed
wembley security without a ticket
during the euro 2020 final following 15
hours of drinking and the guardian leads
with a climate story
they say that the balance has tipped in
the amazon as the rainforest now emits
more
carbon dioxide than it absorbs
so kevin alley with their choices um
starting with the metro
and masks this is after wales joined
scotland
joined the london mayor and regional
mayors in suggesting that uh
ali that mosque should still be
mandatory where does this leave the
government then
well and i think the government's in a
little bit of a mess on this one uh we
know that
in the last couple of weeks when sajid
javid became the new health sector
the tone from the government actually
changed ahead of this
big re-opening uh next monday uh but
since then uh in the light of the fact
that uh the polling is showing that the
the public is actually quite in favor of
uh the retention of mosques
the government has rode back from that
position uh quite a lot and is now
placing the onus
on transport providers who actually make
the decision on mask enforcement so it's
not going to be mandatory in law
but they're pushing it down to in this
case um
tfl the deep khan has actually said that
he will make it mandatory it's not going
to be mandatory in law
but what this means is that station
staff
are going to have to be put in this
awkward position of confronting people
where they don't really have mandatory
powers in law to do that which is going
to put them in an awkward position
and it also is at odds with as you say
what's happening in wales
and scotland so i think the buck is
being passed we've got to remember that
masks the government was very late to
introduce master in the first place last
june they introduced them on public
transport and july in shop
months after the the first lockdown took
place in march so they'd be they were
late to impose them
and now they're early to remove them so
it's a bit of a mess i think yes and
indeed
the mirror i know for wednesday's paper
did a big double page spread about about
face on masks
today though the transport secretary
grant shaps um immediately urged rail
firms to follow
you know the london mayor city khan and
scotland at the time
saying it's very much in line with what
we expected indeed wanted to happen
um is that fair do you think
i would say no i know if that's what the
transport secretary
wanted to happen then the transport
secretary leaves it in law then it would
then it will
happen it's almost uh book passing here
he's outsourced
the decision to others where he should
say no look i will make this work
because it is going to be chaos around
the country and i understand why um some
staff
fear as the the rmt union said the rail
union which represents a lot of
sort of rail workers on ticket barriers
and
and so on that uh people who will say no
no we don't have to wear a mask but you
wanted to wear a mask
could you please wear a mask and they
say say no and you can get these
confrontations because it's going to be
a real best acidic con in london has the
power by
by changing uh regulations to
almost make it make it a a condition
that you have to
uh you have to follow to go on the
system but we saw with the metro mayors
the five
metro mayors coming together five labour
metro mayors including tracy
braven in western they have the power to
enforce
mass wearing she can require masks to be
worn
in a bus station but the moment the buzz
pulls up and somebody gets on the bus
she doesn't have the power
to compel that and andy street the west
midlands mayor is also in the same
position he wants masks
to be worn on public transport but it
can't be enforced i think the
government's got this
wrong politically and i think they're
they're behind
public opinion as ali said because most
people think wearing masks
should remain a legal requirement on
public transport and i would also
suggest in shops too particularly if you
want to
uh you want to protect those shop
workers as well as the as the customers
and the government was slow to the party
on this but in fairness to the
to the government the world health
organization was slow too and didn't
change
its guidance until uh earlier this year
because the whole focus was on
passing um covid through through contact
touch
and the fact he could be airborne and
transmitted that way was
was overlooked for too long yes uh those
metro mayors
cover a wide area too as you said west
yorkshire greater manchester
liverpool city region north of tyne west
of england and south yorkshire
doubling up with the labour mayor in
london but a series of
government advice has been published uh
ali including
coming back to the office advice for
businesses uh which the telegraph
reports that
pubs restaurants and bars are being
urged to check
vaccine passports this is interesting
isn't it because before it was
it felt like it was going to be
nightclubs and that was it what's the
story here
well look i have a specific interest in
nightclubs as you know anna because i've
got a gig coming up in shoreditch on
august the 13th
where i should be spinning the deck so i
have an interest in getting this
in this right but it's now moved on from
nightclub
it's now uh restaurants as you say and
other hospitality venues
that have already had a torrid time
their takings are
way down they still have to comply up
till now with social distancing
so they've got enough on their plate to
deal with again i think this is the
government
trying to pass the buck a little bit
here and not being clear and it's
in its actual uh mandatory requirements
of what it actually wants i mean
there is still a feeling amongst the
public and this is also borne out in
other countries with france
uh requiring these things uh by law
portugal introducing these measures as
well
that we seem to be going against the
grain here by leaving it up to
individuals and in this case
the hospitality sector to decide these
things i think what they want
is clear rules this is uh difficult
because you're going to have a
hot spot of certain restaurants imposing
this others not
and then you get this uh division going
on and again impositions on staff
and we're also seeing a number of people
also
getting ping the the infection rates
above 40 000
now the death rates are going up uh so i
still think you know these these
precautions should be
being looked at by the by the government
and then being imposed in law rather
than
pushing it on to the venues to decide
for themselves
so the the mood music from the
government freedom day
ministers i can't wait to get my mask
off has now sort of shifted has it not
um the mail reporting that masks indoors
plastic screens a slow return to work
why your office after freedom day will
look remarkably like it does now
the advice to people who are shielding
this advice to hospitality
it's all way more cautious than the than
the tone that was set by the government
before last monday
no absolutely uh and i think the the
prime minister was all gong
gung-ho but he's now he's seen those
figures rising
for 40 10 42 000 fresh infections high
since
mid-january the link with death is
severely weakened but there were 49
nonetheless
uh reported in the latest 24-hour period
and i think he
he wants to pull off all the legal
restrictions as many as he
can but then shift responsibility
onto businesses whether you're a pub a
club a cafe
a shop operating public transport and
it's almost as if he's trying to wash
his hands
legally now of responsibility i think
that uh
that is a mistake because one we were
told covered passports
wouldn't be coming in so they want them
now to come in in an informal way
but two do you really think pubs cafe
restaurants are going to be
turning away customers if they don't
have covered passports when that's not
required in law
up to now you were asked to uh
to check in with your phone you didn't
have your phone most places required you
to
write your name and your your number
well that's not gonna that's
gonna be required now but they're not
going to say what you haven't got any
proof you're double jabbed
so you can't come in we just know it
ain't it ain't gonna happen because if
people can't get in one pub
uh because it is enforced they'll go to
another pub where it isn't enforced and
the pub that's enforcing it will realize
it hasn't got any customers
so they'll they'll stop doing it it's
lifting the whole legal architecture in
this way
is a huge risk and a gamble and he knows
that
johnson but he does seem to be trying to
blame others and he's gonna
blame businesses that have had a
terrible time
if it all goes wrong yes um it's hard to
do test and trace without any tracing
isn't it uh
and i think there have been protests in
the streets of paris after
macron said that covert passports are on
are a necessity
and ali all very well having rising
cases but they don't happen in isolation
as the ft reports
the delta variant is wreaking havoc on
industry the paper says
with more than 700 workers at the uk's
largest car factory now self-isolating
business groups warning that some
companies are missing 20
of their staff labor shortages they say
have hit factories shops warehouses
with workers pinged by the nhs covered
app told to isolate etc etc it's not the
first time we've heard this but it
presumably will only get worse
i think there is a problem here because
there's a disconnect between this july
the 19th
grand reopening date and the fact that
the restrictions on uh if you're pinged
uh remaining at home for 10 days in
self-isolation
are only going to be lifted on august
the 16th so
until that period you have this
situation where
a number of people in the country i mean
66 percent have been double jab by now
but there are
many who haven't been double jabs and
even the people who are being double jab
have been double jab rather um can still
pick up the infection so
you've got this situation where until
you get
uh to a later point in the year a number
of people are going to
end up getting pinged by the nhs test
and tracer and are going to have to sit
at home for 10 days now
this is causing serious problems it's
causing problems to
nissan on its production car plant up in
sunderland
it's also causing problems for iceland
where you know um
causes problems for me because i like
the bread that they serve in iceland so
i'll be disappointed if there are
shortages of that on the shelf so there
are serious problems out there
and we see that the cbi is pleading with
the government
to actually uh try and bring this date
forward
uh to monday to abandon this uh
requirement to stay at home for 10 days
because of the fact that it's going to
affect so many workers and this is
before you get anna to the nhs
and the impact on the nhs stuff we've
already got a back level of five million
operations
and this is all also going to affect the
number of nhs star
and increase that backlog even more yes
and and
the the ft suggesting that hospitals in
leeds and birmingham
among those having had to cancel
postpone operations in part because so
many staff are self-isolating
certainly the nhs is probably where
they'll look at that first
both of you stay there thank you very
much indeed for now but plans to
impose banning orders on football fans
who exhibit racist behavior is where we
turn our attention next back in just a
moment
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me now kevin maguire
and ali mirage welcome back to both of
you
um so clearly uh the football um the
racism
uh the social media companies and what
to do about it has been part of the
debate since uh since sunday's
final which takes us to the metro and
this idea about
banning orders kevin doesn't it yeah no
absolutely which which labour have also
called for kia stoma but
boris johnson the prime minister's
question said uh you
have football supporters or people found
guilty of racist abuse
online will be banned from going to
games it happens at the moment with
those
who are convicted of a violence or other
offences
at football games um you wonder why
it's it's just those online i mean would
you say
whoever defaced the mark was rashford
mural for instance shouldn't be banned
um but it there's a petition calling for
um i think it's signed by about a
million people now calling for a
lifetime
ban from football on these people i
wouldn't actually support i'm not going
to be soft on racist or racist but i do
believe in
redemption and education and people
changing as
well as as punishment but you can see
the the prime minister wants to try and
get a bit
to attack because he's a very torrent
time
in that the culture war he he started is
now
losing the battle and it began really
once
the team became incredibly popular and
he'd made that big mistake at the
beginning refusing
to condemn those who were gonna boo
players when they took the knee
well all the racist abuses shown exactly
why
footballers feel the need to take the
knee
and he struggled up promises questions
too over trying to defend
uh the home secretary after calling
taking the knee just your politics
breathing in boris johnson's all about
just your politics that's what
that's what gets him him going but i
think
he just backed the wrong side in this i
think it says a lot about him that isn't
pleasant and he backed the wrong side
yeah this is the suggestion kevin that
too much focus against woke than on the
fight against racism
but 30 seconds left ali lucky you you've
got the front page of the sun to talk us
through
well what can one say i mean this is a
person who had
been drinking for hours uh had
taken cocaine tons of alcohol and put a
live player in his
posterior so uh you know whatever floats
your boat i guess but
um he's not going to be going to any
more football matches but the problem
with all of this is anna that it really
messes up our chances to host the world
cup
in 2030 in a joint bid with ireland i
mean with this sort of behavior going on
and it is a fringe of fans i mean
most football fans just want to enjoy it
sorry to rush you ally mirage kevin
mcguire
thank you